a California man is shot and killed
following a three-hour long police
standoff after he's caught on security
camera walking around with an ax
drinking vodka and seemingly snorting
cocaine come back to me don't reach for
the gun if you reach for the gun I'm
gonna shoot you
to deliver a lethal
fire exhaust fire
let's go in there
go go
the incident unfolded on May 19th in the
Glen Park neighborhood of San Francisco
at about 2 20 that afternoon a man
called 9-1-1 reporting his neighbor
broke into his apartment with a weapon
San Francisco police released a
recording of the 9-1-1 call but
distorted the caller's voice to keep his
identity private are you outside right
now
outside right now he's inside okay yes
okay I need you to stay on the line for
me okay
he lives here
he broke in my house
the caller then gives dispatch a
description of the suspect okay copy so
let me get a description so did you see
the gun
she has a gun did you see it yes
okay what color was the gun do you know
what type of gun I don't I don't like
brown okay
what race is this person who broke in
white blood pressure okay male or female
okay how old does he appear to be he's
probably around 42 40 years old
around five five three five three heavy
five million five or ten field
what color shirt was he wearing they
just said I read I saw the ribs
black pants besides you see any weapons
on him
yeah I saw the weapon the other weapon
okay I'm asking beside that done did you
see any other weapon no okay
he also tells dispatch he knows the
suspect and gives a name officials later
confirmed the caller gave an incorrect
name after they identify the suspect as
40 year old Sergio Barrios do you know
the name for this person
yes what is this name
he has a record already okay what's the
Laughing do you know his last name
probably Rivera
body camera video shows San Francisco
officers arrive on the scene speaking
with a man who called 9-1-1
[Music]
Under the Stairs
hey over here
he's not going to go outside okay he's
going to have to come out here he can go
out that way
he's downstairs he lives in apartment
it's getting entry to the back door on
the rear of the building
so let's make it like the same three
we'll be here real quick
security video shows Barrios in the
outfit the 9-1-1 caller described he's
also caught on camera walking back and
forth with an ax after that an officer
makes contact with Barrios who is now
armed with a gun
hey we got a moving on two three hey
the officer repeatedly calls for Barrios
to drop the weapon he has body camera
video captures audio of the weapon
hitting the ground when Barrios drops it
drop the gun drop the gun
hey drop the guy drop the gun drop the
gun come out
turn around and come back to me
turn around come back to me
come back walk back to me
walk back
walk back let him know he dropped the
gun but after dropping the weapon
Barrios does not walk toward officers as
he's commanded to officers then warn him
if he reaches for the weapon he will be
shot come back to me
and put your hands up hands on top of
your head
come back drop the Ballers and come back
to me come back
come back
and don't reach for the gun come back
come back to me
come back
hands up here drop the bottles turn
around and come back
come back to me
don't reach for the gun if you reach for
the gun I'm gonna shoot you
come back come back here the guns the
guns within reach the distance right at
his right foot come back to me okay
come back don't reach for the gun I'll
shoot you
come back
come back here
the gun's on his right foot on the
ground instead of walking toward
officers Barrios is seen on security
camera video appearing to snort cocaine
this continues for several minutes
meanwhile crisis hostage negotiators
meet in a nearby police Bearcat vehicle
Philadelphia
officers can be heard discussing the
current situation and how to get Barrios
to cooperate
has he said anything
no he's a guy by his feet
and uh we try to reach where it once
and then
[Music]
so is he out outside in the house they
have eyes on him yeah okay and you're
basically just coaching like hey I'm
just telling him to come up with a hands
up we don't want to hurt we just want to
help him out don't touch his gun and
just come out do the officers on the
door so they can help you do we know if
they're responding at all he's
responding backwards at all he's on the
other influence because they got his
phone out a crisis negotiation officer
speaks to Barrios in Spanish saying
people close to him are concerned for
his safety their names have also been
removed from the video to keep their
identities private just keep just keep
reiterating like Hey we're here to help
you know we just want to just walk
towards us so we can take care of this
foreign
later a message recorded by one of
barrios's family members is played aloud
go ahead
[Music]
okay
Barrios is later seen removing a rosary
from around his neck
he's taking off the crucifix
after this things move quickly body
camera video shows officer Gregory
boohager on the roof of a nearby
building armed with a gun when Barrio
seemingly reaches for the gun laying on
the ground near him boo hagger opens
fire
no no
shots fired yeah
shots fired
hey we're moving down
body camera video from another officer
who deployed a less Lethal Weapon in
barrios's Direction shows the moments
following the shooting from another
angle
hey
do we just deliver a lethal
shots fired shots fired let's go in
there
I got it I got it I got it I got it
covered
[Music]
foreign
is caught on two more body camera
recordings oh
shots fired shots fired
up
oh hey
officials say First Responders began
performing life-saving measures on
Barrios about 30 seconds after the
shooting he later died at the hospital
from here the San Francisco County
District Attorney's office will
determine whether officer boo hacker is
charged criminally officials say he's a
22-year veteran of the San Francisco
Police Department reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie